if every year 2.5% zakat on savings or
jewelry is given is
paid after 40 years there would be
nothing
remaining is this a trick
question many people think that if you
keep on giving 2 and half% zakat so 2
and half multip by 40 becom 100% you
give 2 and half% every year then at the
end of 40 years you'll be left with
nothing actually the match is a bit weak
because zakat is given on what they have
for one full year so if for example
someone has maybe 100 Gams of gold so he
has to pay zakat for the first year 2
and half% that is 2 and a half grams of
gold next year he has to pay 2 and 1
half% on 97 and half grams not on 100 G
so which will be less than two and half
gram gold so it will take much more than
20 years and the
full asset can never be nil it can never
be even if hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years but will never be nil
it will keep on diminishing something
will be left but again the moment it
reaches a nisab level just after a few
years if the lady gets 2 and half% maybe
about for a few years maybe 5 years 10
years 15
years within a few years from 5 to 10
years it will reach a nisab level the
moment it goes below 85 gr of gold which
will take somewhere close to about 10
years or a little bit more moment
reaches below nisab level then you stop
paying
Zak or if a person has a th g gold he
keeps on
giving but the moment reaches n they
stop giving gold so never can it be zero
even practically if they keep on giving
even below it will not reach zero but
the moment ACC to Islamic Sharia they
don't have to give zakat so that's the
reason alhamdulillah this tax is levied
every Luna
year for the answer